all right we're sitting here on the set
of our book Expo America borders world
with Gary Vaynerchuk who's the author of
a brand new book it's called crush it
Gary tell me the subtitle of your book
crush it why now is the time to cash in
on your passion right and I believe that
very much
I think what we've seen in the last 24
to 36 months in the business world in
society with the way the Internet has
transformed with these social products
like Twitter and Facebook and Tumblr and
Ustream we have very different worlds
and there's a lot of opportunity and I
want to expose that opportunity yeah you
started and you still are in wine you
got really interested in wine and you're
in your New Jersey business and somehow
or another decided to take your
interesting line to the web and create
Wine Library TV how did that happen
pulse you know a lot of what I talk
about in the book is about not what's
going on today but what's going on three
years from now six years from now the
more you have the ability to figure that
out the more opportunity there's in oh
five it became obvious to me that video
online was gonna have a place you know
mainstream America started talking about
YouTube not just the internet nerds you
know things like that I said okay
there's something here I've got this
huge passion for wine wine is Miss
position that people are not treating it
the way I want them to which is
trust your own palate don't listen
anybody else the Wine Spectator Robert
Parker or me let me start the show talk
about it and empower build self-esteem
to the viewer and so February of oh six
sat down camera in my office and haven't
stopped since it's become huge right how
many how many people are watching this
almost a hundred thousand a day you know
and it's led to Conan O'Brien into
today's show and Nightline and a lot of
exposure you know half a million Twitter
followers a lot of craziness has come
from it another Lee Leto 7 I started
transitioning my brand into the other
thing I'm passionate about which is
building brand building businesses and
that's what the book is gonna be really
about yeah you took all these tools that
were available to anyone available to
anybody out there and you turn them into
something really powerful for yourself
it looks like you now want to share that
with a whole bunch of people the idea
though of using the web to your
advantage anybody can go grab it anybody
can do it but it's not just getting on
it and doing it you do got it work it
you know the web and its tools again all
these fancy things like Facebook and
Twitter they're tools
it's like going out and buying a hammer
and a drill okay now you gotta go use it
and okay there's carpenters that are
better than other carpenters and so it's
about understanding how to use it
being transparent being authentic not
trying to bull crap your viewers passion
you know to me what is that one thing
that you would do for free what do you
want to do for the rest of your life I
go through the overview of why it's
possible why what I do today probably
would have cost a million dollars a year
in expenses just a couple years ago and
that would have put me out of business
and why that's not true any longer and
more importantly finding that thing that
really gets you excited really puts you
in a place where even making forty-five
thousand dollars a year on it would be
the greatest thing that ever could
happen to you that that opportunity is
out there and I want to expose it well
you have a ton of passion obviously not
just for the wine and all the things
that's now moved up to sharing what you
know with other people but how do you
find that if you don't know what it is
there's a ton of people who aren't sure
what that is
you know and that's just something that
you got to look within yourself I think
people you know I think people are
scared you know somebody out there is
most passionate about carebears
the cartoon from the 80s and I think
there's no way I can make money on that
but there is the scary part is there's
tens if not hundreds if not millions of
people out there that have that same
passion and the ability for anybody
whether by the way it's a book retailer
an author a collector a coffee shop
owner a gardener the ability to put out
content around your passion and what you
do is out there for everybody
zero cost huge reward total GameChanger
and it's time for people to realize that
opportunity you said authentic though
earlier there's a lot of bad content out
there there's a lot of better there's a
lot of bad books written right well of
course it's just a game but so where
does I mean the authentic thing is so
important I agree with you
you have to go out there and it has to
feel real if it ever feels like you're
selling or you're Hawkins you're dead
yeah so how do you make sure I mean what
have you done to make sure that the
stuff you're doing be true fear of
knowing that if I start trying to go too
far in one direction or the other that
uh that there is a danger listen this
book right I mean I'm so passionate
about this book I want everybody in the
world to read it so you know I'm a
natural salesman I had a lemonade stand
I was a baseball card kid I want to
bring it up everywhere but I don't
because I don't want to be too pitchy
with it and so it's a balance it's
having feel but if you're coming from a
place of truth and care you're gonna win
it's it's like Twitter very hot topic
Gary you have so many followers you did
it Wow how do you use it it's not what
do I say it's not about what you say
it's about how you listen to the people
talking to you and so it's those kind of
basic human principles treat Twitter and
Facebook like a cocktail party and
you'll win you're not gonna pitch your
stuff that a cocktail party you may drop
a line to your neighbors but you're not
gonna pitch a lot of people do with
Twitter just a lot of businesses
especially will just drop there they'll
just keep posting press release for them
so how do you you know for you it sounds
like you're it's all about the followers
and all about following others as well
yeah I mean it's a balance I mean
Twitter's funny for me I probably use it
more as a hey check this out I'm
speaking up VA you know see me on TV I
do use it as a communication tool but
there's a lot of me watching every
single day I'm searching my name 40
times a day what are people saying do
they need me somebody says hey Gary Vee
what wine goes with pork loin I'm
getting in there I'm sending a direct
message saying you got to look at the
tea for now it's an amazing
up-and-coming grape that means I mean to
people that's like are you kidding me
and these massive mainstream brands I
mean do you know what it would be like
if I said to my favorite Jets player hey
you know Thomas Jones hey Kerry Rhodes
what do you think about the game and
they sent me a direct message saying
we're gonna win
that's so much deeper than anything that
was ever out there before that's the
power of it yeah but it's hard to do
that when you're Chania busy how many
you're answering emails you're on
Twitter Facebook every time they invent
new social network Merrill how can you
do it on it's your job you know the more
you put in the more you get I mean
you're not gonna buy a yacht or buy the
New York Jets like I want to if you
don't work hard it's about effort and if
you put in 30 minutes you get 30 minute
results yeah so a lot of people ask me
that I do a lot of consulting for
fortune 500 companies and they're always
like okay wait a minute
when are we supposed to do our real job
and I'm like well your real job consists
of 45 minutes of you watching bullcrap
videos on the internet twenty-five
minutes of you instant messaging with
your friends an hour of you dozing off I
mean this is real this is connecting
this is touching this is the pulse of
our society and these platforms are free
we're talking about sweat equity in
return for real money
that's crazy yeah so you're a big fan of
a Facebook and Twitter I am you see
other elements out there that are common
tumblr I think tumblr is gonna be a big
play very big on Ustream and even by the
time October comes out and this book
comes out they'll probably one or two
more I mean there's so much going on out
there it's happening every day but those
two have really settled in they're
definitely the buzz words but WordPress
you know and tumblr they're your
platforms to build your blog is a
blogging tool correct WordPress is a
block I think Twitter and Facebook are
great but I still think people need
their destination where's your home you
know - Wine Library TV and
garyvaynerchuk.com
these tools are you know in place to
maybe bring eyeballs to your home and I
think that's important for people that
understand well clearly Facebook a
struck a chord with a lot of people now
and that I mean it started with a lot of
younger kids yes
college students college play and then
now a lot of people in the 35 and over
set moving into Facebook huge numbers
reconnecting with old classmates yes it
is their home to something right now and
if grandma wants to see the grandkids
that's right the pictures are on face in
a out class silly it's funny three four
years ago I was screaming about how and
I was like oh nobody over 30 this is a
young man's young woman's game this is
Society the Internet itself is the
biggest platform of media ever people
need to wrap their head around it and
it's 14 years old yeah I mean it's just
it's
sending to me so who is the biggest
audience for crushing is it individuals
is it companies is that teachers is a
who I would say it starts with
individuals anybody who does not want to
not go to sleep at night because they're
so happy with what they do should buy
this book then corporate because I think
corporate needs to understand the
environment they need to build within
their industries to allow freedom for
their employees or they're gonna start
losing their a players because the a
player's ability to go out there and
reproduce what I've done is easy so I
would say in that order
okay so what's gonna happen with your
wine passion now you're getting to be
Gary you know Vaynerchuk now this new
guy there's like this sort of you know
business school or in person you know so
what's gonna happen to the gay
Vaynerchuk the vayniacs the wine fans my
DNA is is always with me I didn't stop
liking the Jets cuz I got into wine and
listen I'm still pumping out Wine
Library TV every single day how many
episodes a day
we're almost at 705 episodes a week
every single day 30-minute wine shows in
that camera so I I don't see it stopping
on let you know I'm having a baby
there's dynamics in my life but it's
such a part of me I mean I'm just
whining is not where I want it to be so
I still have a lot of work to do how do
you wind down at the end of the day I
don't they're like rolling I don't it
just it goes too straight you know
switch off and that's it like alright
and then you know I'm out yeah so how's
your baby gonna keep up with that man I
don't know I mean how am I gonna keep up
with the baby I think it's a bigger
concern right well listen I wish you the
best of luck
thank you for having luck to the Jets to
appreciate it and thanks so much for
coming to borders I know the book is
gonna rock thank you so much